aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par guillaume mazeau et grâce à
son travail
on va comprendre comment l'histoire
traverse les époques avec succès
[Musique]
il ya quelques années un dialogue
imaginaire entre un client et un employé
de burger king est devenue virale sur
les réseaux sociaux
je pourrais avoir hopper sans fromage la
machine à vos peurs et casser la
réplique renvoie à une expérience
fréquente des consommateurs de fast food
et remporte un franc succès est encore
mieux de nombreuses variantes sont créés
ce qui transforme le dialogue en même
donc en une image ou une phrase où les
deux reprises et transformé en masse une
variante de ce même évoque la révolution
française robespierre prend la place du
client et ne demande pas un hamburger
mais il dit
les beatles john dalli donc il demande
qu'on lui permette de purger en gironde
dans la deuxième case une gravure de
décapitation est accompagnée de la
phrase guillotine machine broc
la machine est guillotiné cassé et dans
la troisième et dernière case le même
robespierre qu'au début les yeux rouges
et lumineux répond beach fixed à django
reinhardt prépare moi ça tout de
suite
alors excusez ma vulgarité c'est pas du
tout mon style je ne fais que décrire ce
que je vois cette image nous montre que
l'histoire continue à vivre dans notre
quotidien et pas seulement dans les
livres ou les monde savant en fait même
chez les populations à priori étrangère
à la révolution française robespierre
continue d'être vu comme un monstre
révolutionnaire pour guillaume mazeau
internet ces réseaux comme forte
jeanneret dit tumblr ou encore instagram
twitter et facebook ont permis aux
images de contribuer à l'écriture
collective de l'histoire et si on se
penche un peu plus sur l'image on
réalise autre chose le portrait de
robespierre ce n'est pas n'importe
lequel
c'est un tableau anonyme de qualité
conservée au musée carnavalet et la
victime ce n'est pas n'importe laquelle
non plus c'est un girondin
donc ces républicains modérés qui
s'opposaient à la république sociale
incarnée par robespierre
en fait même la zombification de
robespierre dans la dernière case n'est
pas tant que ça un des leurs
contemporains il ya plus de 200 ans
les contre révolutionnaires représentait
souvent les jacobins comme des monstres
et des vampires qui revenait d enfer
pour répandre la révolution et semer la
mort et enfin pour la peine de
guillotine elle évoque les gravures du
directoire qui montre et robespierre
comme le seul survivant au milieu d'une
forêt de machines à l'arrêt pour leur
présenter comme l'unique bourreau de la
terreur donc de la même façon que pour
les anciennes gravures ou les
lithographies du 19e siècle les mêmes
transporte et transforme l'imaginaire
des événements passés
plus encore ils permettent aussi de le
comprendre d'une nouvelle manière
merci à guillaume mazeau qui nous a
permis de faire cette vidéo et à bientôt
sur une image une histoire
[Musique]
m